looking at it collapsed interstate
overpass in Atlanta that tumbled down in
a massive fire it is causing major
traffic headaches this morning and the
city is under a state of emergency
Georgia officials are investigating the
cause of yesterday's rush-hour fire the
closure of i-85 a key north-south artery
is causing huge backups across one of
the country's largest metro areas
mark Strassmann is near the scene of the
collapse in Atlanta mark good morning
good morning I'm standing about 30 yards
from the collapsed overpass you can see
a smoke rising from the rubble the
concrete rubble behind me firefighters
were also putting out the flames
this morning's commute here could be
historically bad both the northbound and
southbound lanes of i-85 that's eight
lanes and all are closed a quarter
million cars a day use these highway and
they're gonna have to find another way I
want to show you a different look which
is from our drone can I mean take a look
at this it really is remarkable that no
one was hurt or killed and here's why
when the flames broke out right away
police shut down traffic and stopped the
cars from going over the overpass so
nothing was on the overpass when it fell
the second lifesaver was responding
firefighters under the overpass noticed
that concrete above them was crumbling
and evacuated just a couple of minutes
before the whole thing came tumbling
down thick billowing smoke and a tower
of flame rose over i-80 5 near downtown
Atlanta Thursday as emergency crews
rushed to put out a massive fire burning
under a freeway overpass at rush hour
hold on
oh my
the overpass eventually collapsed from
heat officials are still unclear what
started the fire
Georgia governor nathan Deal I heard was
that it was some PVC products that
caught fire I do not know why they did
or what the source of their transport
was but those are those are questions
that will hopefully be answered I'm
worried this is gonna close 85 for a
long long time I 85 is a major artery
that runs north to south through the
heart of metro Atlanta averaging a
quarter million cars a day on its roads
this incident make no bones about it
will have a tremendous impact to travel
the impact was felt immediately cars
littered the paralyzed Highway snarling
traffic well into the evening the backup
stretched for miles we've been in uber
for over two hours and we had like one
point four miles to go this is minor
compared to what the firefighters and
everyone else is dealing with the pork
has just been put in the bottle think
about one of the major arteries that
comes in and out of this city where
folks move north and south a chunk of it
has just been taken out of play one more
live look now at this collapsed overpass
Atlanta is notorious for terrible
traffic everyone's lifestyle here is
affected by how long it's going to take
to get from here to there and
bumper-to-bumper traffic this is a
project replacing this missing piece
that's going to go on for weeks if not
months
this city's commute is going to go from
bad to brutal Alex it's a dramatic scene
down there miracle known was hurt thank
you Mark